mesdames messieurs bon dimanche le
verdict est sans équivoque
98,61% c'est le résultat du vote de
confiance auquel François Legault a dû
se soumettre cette fin de semaine les
quelques milles délégués de la CAF
réunis en congrès à Sherbrooke demeure
donc résolument derrière leur chef
malgré un début de seconde mandat plus
difficile marqué entre autres par la
controverse entourant l'annulation du
projet de troisième lien autoroutier et
dire que François Legault peut
maintenant tourner la page on prend des
décisions qui sont parfois
difficiles j'ai appris à le dire ça
serait bien
et
[Applaudissements]
des fois
on peut décevoir quand on prend des
décisions et
par contre je peux vous garantir une
chose à chaque jour que quand je me lève
j'essaye de faire le mieux que je peux
avec toute mon cœur pour le bien des
Québécois puis
cette étape là dans le dos que vous me
donnez aujourd'hui
ça me fait du bien compenser la vis
première ministre ministre des
Transports et de la mobilité durable je
rejoins un Geneviève Guilbaud à
Sherbrooke bonjour madame Guilbaud
bonjour monsieur Thibault bon écoutez
votre chef a obtenu
98.61%
c'est un énorme score c'est plus
important que celui de 2017 comment vous
expliquer ça malgré le début de mandat
de deuxième mandat avait été facile pour
votre gouvernement
non vous avez raison le deuxième mandat
pas comme le premier beaucoup beaucoup
de défis à relever ensemble de continuer
ce qu'on a entamé au premier mandat
malgré une pandémie qui nous a veulent
pas un peu court-circuiter dans
certaines choses qu'on voulait qu'on
voulait accomplir donc c'est quand même
un mandat qui est important où on va
devoir relever certains défis comme je
disais accumulé du premier mandat et
pour suivre les changements qu'on a
voulu mettre en place au premier mandat
mais qui ont été un petit peu disons
influencés par une pandémie dont on a dû
s'occuper en priorité pendant deux trois
ans mais
honnêtement aujourd'hui là moi je suis
tellement fier vraiment moi je suis pas
gênée de dire que j'ai voté oui pour le
vote de confiance de notre chef médecine
notre chef
c'est notre premier ministre mais c'est
d'abord et avant tout le chef de la
Coalition Québec on est 90 députés c'est
beaucoup de gens donc et de tout les
Québécois et c'est un homme moi
personnellement que j'admire tellement
j'ai choisi de me joindre dans la
coalition de Québec moi bien avant qu'on
soit haut dans les sondages donc c'est
un homme que moi me convaincre me
rallier qui a fondé son propre parti en
2011 en disant moi je veux fonder un
parti qui va être très économique et
très nationaliste qui va nous sortir des
vieilles chicanes de souveraineté tout
ça et qui sept ans plus tard en 2018 a
réussi à porter ce parti-là au pouvoir
donc c'est quand même pour rien c'est
qu'on aime ou non la CAQ qu'il faut
reconnaître
le talent et l'intelligence de cette
personne-là la compétence et son amour
profond du Québec et des Québécois et ça
c'est ça s'est manifesté aujourd'hui
avec un vote de confiance comme vous
l'avez dit avec un score de près de 100%
alors moi je suis très fier de mon chef
l'effet 3e lien c'est pas fait c'est pas
fait sentir dans le vote de confiance
mais est-ce que il y a encore de la
grogne sur le terrain est-ce que les
délégués vous en parle de cette question
là est-ce que vous en entendez parler
sur le parquet bien franchement moi ici
je suis ici depuis hier matin à 9h
depuis que ça a commencé le Congrès
samedi et il y a personne qui m'en a
parlé par contre je suis certaine que
des gens qui en ont peut-être parlé à
certains de mes collègues et je suis
certaine qu'il y a des gens dans la
capitale nationale dans chaudière à
Palach qui sont insatisfaits qui sont
déçus qui sont en colère qui sont
tristes et moi ce que je dis tout le
temps puis avec mes on est neuf députés
de la CAQ dans la région de dans la
grande capitale nationale on est 7
députés de la casse dans shooter à
Palace les gens doivent se sentir à
l'aise de venir nous le dire on n'est
pas payé là les politiciens pour faire
juste ce qui est plaisant ou juste ce
qui est facile les gens doivent se
sentir à l'aise de venir nous le dire et
c'est tout à fait correct on a pris une
décision qui a été très très difficile
dans une scène gestion des fonds publics
compte tenu des effets de la pandémie
sur la vie des Québécois sur les
habitudes de déplacement des Québécois
vraiment pas été facile de prendre cette
décision là je peux vous le dire là je
suis ministre des Transports alors et
donc et donc ça a été difficile et moi
je veux que les gens se sentent à l'aise
on reçoit beaucoup de courriels on
reçoit des appels que ce soit pour ou
contre le troisième lien alors c'est
normal que les politiciens reçoivent les
commentaires des gens qui soient
positifs ou négatifs alors sans ton nous
sentons nous très à l'aise le dire ici
personne n'en a parlé
je suis surprise je suis surprise moi
aussi je dois le dire mais donc les gens
sont très de bonne humeur je dois dire
que l'ambiance est très bonne ici depuis
deux jours les gens sont de bonne humeur
on est content il y a eu des
propositions très intéressantes qui ont
été débattues hier notamment sur le
transport notamment sur l'énergie
l'énergie la transition énergétique je
vous dirais ça fait l'objet de beaucoup
beaucoup de discussions c'est le début
de société qu'on doit avoir des filles
en électricité et autres alors
l'ambiance est bonne parlons-en du
transport justement parce qu'il y a eu
des résolutions entre autres sur la
question de construction d'un TGV entre
Québec et Montréal vous êtes la ministre
des Transports là pour l'instant on le
fédéral semble davantage prioriser un
train à grande fréquence vous pensez
quoi vous êtes TGV nous on aimerait un
TGV parce que moi je pense puis depuis
que je suis au transport encore plus la
vitesse donc le temps de déplacement et
le facteur qui va convaincre les gens de
prendre le train plutôt que leur voiture
alors oui la fréquence par contre je
suis d'accord sur la fréquence pour que
le train passe souvent il faut que tu
puisses à la Québec à Toronto ou
ailleurs ou à Montréal et savoir que tu
vas pouvoir y aller puis revenir à des
heures qui te conviennent mais la
vitesse aussi en ce moment il y a des
enjeux parce qu'on partage les rails tu
sais donc des fois tu prends le train et
là le train est arrêté parce qu'il faut
pas se faire passer les marchandises et
c'est ça qui qui dissuade les gens de
prendre le train plutôt que la voiture
alors la vitesse pour moi c'est un
aspect qui est fondament c'est un énorme
investissement madame Guilbaud je pense
pour la vitesse c'est un énorme
investissement d'aller vers un très
agrandes c'est c'est là où ça a heurte
en général
du gouvernement fédéral alors c'est le
gouvernement fédéral qui va investir
pour ce projet-là c'est correct c'est
normal je vous dirais nous ici là on a
beaucoup beaucoup de pression sur les
finances publiques au Québec on doit
financer nos routes au complet parce que
le fédéral maintenant transfinance
seulement le transport collectif ou à
peu près alors donc il fédéral participe
au transport collectif mais donc je
pense que c'est correct que le fédéral
finance un projet de train entre les
deux je pense pour la vitesse mais en ce
moment pour ce que j'en sais j'ai
discuté avec mon homologue mais c'est
agaprat la ministre des Transports
fédéral et ils ont créé comme un bureau
de projet et donc ils sont en discussion
avec des consortium avec des gens pour
essayer peut-être de faire un mode
hybride alors on va voir le prochain qui
vont nous déposer dans tous les cas moi
je salue le fait que le fédéral veuillez
investir pour un train quel qu'il soit
pour relier des centres économiques
importants alors on va voir le projet
qui vont nous déposer on pourra
commenter le moment venu mais moi je
suis heureuse que le fédéral investisse
dans ce contenu de transport collectif
efficace qui va le rayer des métropoles
économiques vos militants ont également
ont également abordé la question d'un
tarif unique dans les réseaux de
transports en commun pour les jeunes les
étudiants les aînés c'est un initiative
qu'on négligeable pour faire en sorte
que les gens utilisent un moyen de
transport là pour justifier les
investissements que votre gouvernement
injecte à Montréal à Québec entre autres
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'idée d'un
tarif unique comme ça c'est une idée je
vous dirais que le principe c'est une
bonne idée dans un monde idéal il y aura
un tarif unique partout et je dirais
dans un monde idéal tout le monde
pourrait prendre du transport collectif
accessible fréquent de bonnes vitesses
donc c'est pas trop long quand tu le
prends et ça coûte pas cher ça c'est le
monde idéal dans la réalité du Québec
vous savez on a un beau grand territoire
qu'on aime beaucoup des belles régions
des vastes territoires des parcs
nationaux et tout ça mais ça fait en
sorte que on a pas de la densité partout
il y a des endroits où il y a pas de
densité ce qui fait que le transport
collectif doit être fait différemment de
par exemple à Montréal ou à Québec ou à
Gatineau alors compte tenu de cette
réalité là les coûts sont différents les
modes de transport sont différents alors
il faut être réaliste aussi je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de la pression
qu'on a sur les finances publiques à
devoir financer entre autres le maintien
notre réseau routier chez nous on a
33000 km de réseau routiers entretenir
au ministère des Transports sans parler
du développement donc des prolongements
d'autoroute des élargissements
d'autoroutes qui sont nécessaires dans
certains coins où il y a beaucoup de
développement où il y a beaucoup de gens
qui vont s'installer particulier depuis
la pandémie on sait il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont quitté les centres urbains
pour aller dans les régions alors il y a
déjà beaucoup d'investissements qui sont
nécessaires donc il faut prioriser il
faut le faire intelligemment faut
choisir les projets de transport
collectif et c'est sûr que dans tout ça
la part des usagers donc les gens les le
prix l'argent que les gens paient pour
prendre le transport collectif ça fait
partie de la recette de ces de ses
revenus là ça fait partie de ce qui nous
permet de financer notre transport
collectif donc il faut le faire comme il
faut il faut être capable s'il faut être
réaliste il faut être capable de
financer ces projets là mais à terme un
jour peut-être après vous et moi mais un
jour viendra où on aura du transport
collectif tellement bien organisé
partout au Québec que peut-être qu'on
aurait arriver là vous avez été
accueilli par des syndiqués du secteur
public qui qui réclame un ajustement
salariale de New zen de pour cent vous
venez de déposer en chambre un projet de
loi pour majorer le salaire des
difficultés à 30 pour de 30%
, comment vous faites pour justifier ça
devant les salariés du secteur public
sont en pleine de négociation je vous
dirais que ces deux choses différentes
le salaire des élus c'est quelque chose
qui est bien qu'on parle des élus
paradoxalement c'est en dehors de la
politique on en a même un comité
indépendant parce qu'on voulait pas nous
le moi personnellement je me serais pas
mêlée de son honneur comme indépendant
avec deux personnes qui ne sont pas et
qui ont été qui sont même pas de la CAQ
et une personne experte des ressources
humaines une personne que jamais fait de
politique qui expire des ressources
humaines qui ont fait un comité
indépendant qui ont fait un rapport
indépendant et nous on donne suite à ce
sera par là on a fait exprès de prendre
un comité indépendant on lui donne suite
ça fait quand même 20 ans ça fait 20 ans
que le salaire des élus avait pas été
modifié c'est une discussion qui
commence à faire 6 ans que je fais de la
politique ça fait 6 ans que j'entends
parler de ça alors là on s'est proposé
de régler ce problème une fois pour
toute de régler ça de manière
indépendante par des gens qui sont en
politique en ce moment on donne une
suite à leur rapport et ensuite de ça on
passe à autre chose
qu'on avait merci infiniment d'avoir été
des nôtres Merci à VOUS bonne journée